[Music]
Kim Kardashian is getting super candid I
wouldn't take any of it back now we are
counting down nine things we learned
from her recent stop by The Ellen
DeGeneres Show for starters Kanye played
games at the hospital during the birth
of their third child daughter Chicago we
had a connecting room and Kanye was in
there plain Connect four with his
friends and not really paying attention
but Kim did have support from one of her
famous sisters I made Kourtney be in the
room I was at Kourtney I need you to be
here with me and little Chicago almost
had a different name we were gonna name
her Jo because my grandma Mary Jo or we
were gonna go with grace mm-hmm and then
it was Chicago he really wanted his
mother's name and I love that name too I
just wasn't sure if it's so much to live
up to what was his mom's nonde North's
big sister skills have improved she's
better
uh-huh then when she's better than she
was with st. and two-year-old st. is a
mini genius
he has such amazing vocabulary and I
know it's like such a Kanye thing to say
like oh my kids a genius but like if I'm
saying it then it's like real right now
Kim's new k'kaw body packaging is almost
too hot to handle
it is a mold of my body and I can't show
it I mean I and the 37 year old has one
thing to say about the cheating
allegations against Khloe's boyfriend
Tristan Thompson
like I don't even know how to describe
it besides it's just so
as for Steve Harvey's dis about her
Family Feud skills Kim didn't know
nothing that really the reality star
said he's way off base I'm really good
at games despite what you've heard
oh and Kim didn't know her rapper hubby
was returning to Twitter at night he
came in it was like did you see my
tweets I was like yes I did see your
tweets and I followed him back and
[Music]
[Applause]